as missiles fell on ukrainian cities so
international condemnation rained down
on vladimir putin and the russian attack
early this morning russian troops
invaded ukraine
a free and sovereign country
and once again in the center of europe
innocent women men and children are
dying
of fear for their lives
we condemn this
barbaric attack
from national capitals leader after
leader promised a coordinated an
unprecedented sanctions response aimed
at president putin the russian elite and
the sources and havens of russian wealth
hoping against hope that they will make
a difference
we will limit russia's ability to do
business in dollars euros pounds and yen
to be part of the global economy
will limit their ability to do that
we're going to stunt the ability of to
finance and grow rush the russian
military
we're going to impose major and we're
going to impair their ability to compete
in high-tech 21st century economy we're
taking new powers to target russian
finance earlier the british prime
minister also announced a salvo of
sanctions banning russian companies from
its markets and russia's national
airline from british airport the
measures include asset freezes against
major russian state banks and
individuals and a halt on high-tech
exports those responsible for propping
up putin he said will have nowhere to
hide this includes all the major
manufacturers that support putin's war
machine
describing the russian president in an
address to the nation as a dictator for
all his bombs and tanks and missiles
i don't believe that the russian
dictator will ever subdue the national
feeling of the ukrainians
and their passionate belief that their
country should be free
world leaders have however fallen short
of banning russia from the swift
international payment system through
which moscow receives foreign currency
some european countries fear billions of
dollars of russian debt won't be repaid
to european creditors if moscow's forced
out of the scheme ukraine's urge western
leaders to reconsider
[Applause]
and while determined efforts continue by
a number of countries to supply ukraine
with lethal and defensive weapons no
one's offering to stand shoulder to
shoulder with kiev and fight
we have made it clear that we don't have
any plans and intentional deploying
nato troops to ukraine what we have made
clear is that we have already increased
and we are increasing the presence of
nato troops in the eastern part of the
alliance on nato territory
that will not be a factor in putin's
plans for now
and neighboring countries have other
problems to consider the polish
government says nine reception points
will be opened along ukraine's border to
receive an expected wave of refugees
a country that in recent months has used
force to repel refugees from the middle
east must now brace for ukrainians
fleeing war in their thousands
neve barker al jazeera